chantelle first of all congratulations
on your nursing degree thank you
chantelle is the first person in my
family to spend 12 years
[Music]
is he gonna be so bad when the season
premiere your family was joking about
the fact that it took you a while to
graduate after the thing years
how long did it take you was it was it
really nine or ten years yes and no
i was working as a nurse's assistant
right after i graduated from high school
i started working
in the healthcare field and taking
classes one at a time here and there so
it wasn't like i took a full load and it
still took me a um
extra time to graduate
so i was just taking classes here and
there when i could so yeah it did take
me long
what was so interesting because
throughout the years i've heard some
members of your family questioning your
intelligence or kind of put you in the
whole pretty but dumb girl stereotype
and you told me royal that that chantel
is stupid how do you feel when people
try to box you into that as far as river
because i know that he was throwing some
jabs at me i mean he can come at me when
he gets his degree like what is he doing
well now that your degree is checked off
pedro needs to find a career of his own
and get out the warehouse what is
something you could see him doing that
you think he'll be really good at okay i
have two ideas about this one of the
things that i would love to see pedro
doing is i think he would be a good
firefighter like a sexy strong
firefighter and then you're the nurse
how's it going
but also
pedro he has a lot of charisma he's very
charismatic so i think that he would do
well in anything like business-minded
because he can get like first of all
america's in love with him right now i
feel like he just has that big white
smile and the trustworthy face and he's
a libra so they they can get on libra
okay
there you go you can get away with
anything and
look at your smile you got a big nice
smile so
i feel like
he would do well
business-wise anything business-wise do
you ever fear that he's gonna get
comfortable with you being a nurse and
maybe just relax and allow you to be the
sole breadwinner that is my nightmare
but i don't feel like it's in his
character like i don't feel like that's
him since he is like from a hispanic
background i know that they are they
take a lot of pride in being the
provider so i really don't see that
becoming an issue with us but
yeah it would be a problem with me yeah
it would hurt me if he did well let's
talk about your brother royal where we
are in the season right now beginning of
season three your family really hasn't
spoken to him since his and angenette's
wedding you do believe that angenette
was fishing we believe that she was
fishing for an american guy this whole
scam
it's all related to get
money out of men just turn them off
do you regret anything that went down
would you have done anything differently
in the philippines i don't regret
anything that happened in the
philippines we are family and we should
be able to be honest with one another be
raw be vulnerable and i don't regret
anything well in july and jeanette
revealed that she and royal are
expecting a baby so what was your
initial reaction to that you're gonna be
auntie i was so excited and i still am
like this is such great news my parents
they're gonna be grandparents and i am
super
happy for the both of them well we know
that pedro's been pushing to start a
family too
is that something you see on the horizon
for you too
yeah i want to have a baby i want to
pedro and i we just really want to be
very
strategic with the you know he analyzes
everything
everything has to be just so yeah but it
is something that we want the both of us
i'm finished okay
all right let's go upstairs come on
you and pedro your bodies are on point
the season premiere
washing the cars i'm like oh my goodness
both of y'all are so fit what do you do
to stay in shape pedro and i we do a lot
of fitness routines together like
partner fitness routines and i like it
because it's really fun to sort of see
him get all sweaty
y'all are something else the firefighter
in the nurse situation pinky
the slit y'all are fun
yeah
you've been in this whole 90 day
universe for a while now so i'm sure
you're used to the critics but how do
you feel when people are always
commenting on social media talking about
you've had plastic surgery you said that
you haven't or talking about the fact
that you use a lot of filters i don't
like it when people comment on instagram
or social media that i've had plastic
surgery because i haven't this is the
body that i was born with and honestly
it's not perfect and i feel like it is a
compliment that they would think that
thank you but there's things that i have
to do to like sort of keep everything in
and keep everything together and but i
haven't had any plastic surgery on my
body or my face i did mention that i got
some botox in my um right here and look
it's worn off
girl so it's not permanent it's not
permanent probably needed in the first
place probably not but like when people
come to me and say that i have had
plastic surgery and oh my god her face
has changed you know this is literally
the same face from season one and then
or not season so yeah it's the same face
from season one and it's the same face
from 90 today i'm just 30 years old now
and the makeup has changed i did gain
weight though since they saw me
on my on 90 day because when i was like
a child i was skinny no i'm a woman well
it's working for you honey you look good
[Music]